everything in Star Wars has a story
every character every weapon every
planet every ship it has one of the most
involved taxonomy of any movie universe
ever their visual dictionaries museums a
wiki site all dedicated to the origins
of the characters there are rules for
what belongs in this universe it has a
certain sound a certain look a certain
feel and it's easy to feel like this
galaxy has always had this distinct
clear identity but if you go back I have
a bad feeling about this
all the way back so one of the very
first Star Wars spin-offs that really
wasn't the case come on let's see a
little smile that's better
this is the Star Wars Holiday Special
a TV variety show that aired on CBS on
November 17th 1978 it tells the story of
Chewbacca's journey home to his family
to celebrate a holiday called life day
try to enjoy your life day the entire
cast of the first Star Wars film which
debuted in 1977 made an appearance there
is a lot going on here
Chewbacca's dead [ __ ] she watches
virtual reality softcore porn starring
singer Diahann Carroll
the Golden Girls actress Bea Arthur who
plays a cantina bartender the American
rock band Jefferson Starship performs in
a hologram music video and the Carol
Burnett shows Harvey Korman plays a
cross-dressing cooking show host it's
bad incomprehensible bad cut tape
cupcake now this is not allowed you
promised it you I nobody is allowed to
mention no you can't it's not funny it's
so bad and I mean this kindly if George
sees it it's so bad it's not funny
do you remember making this Christmas
special I think was 1978 No so it
doesn't exist in your or it doesn't it
doesn't exist what if I were to tell you
that I had a little piece of tape right
now but to a large extent the Star Wars
universe has been shaped and explored
through spin-offs just like this through
novels comics and games outside of the
movies and the holiday special is a
fascinating glimpse into that universe
before it became codified when we were
all still figuring out what Star Wars
was when Star Wars first came out a lot
of people expected it to flop at the
time Hollywood was dominated by gritty
dramas with morally ambiguous heroes
even the most successful science fiction
films were slow to turn a profit then
came Star Wars a good versus evil space
opera fantasy film inspired by Flash
Gordon serials and Japanese samurai
epics it was a hard sell
even getting theaters to screen in was a
challenge Fox Studios had to force
theaters that wanted the highly
anticipated movie the other side of
midnight to screen Star Wars as well
then things went a little differently
than expected the movie had an 18-month
run in theaters ultimately grossing over
four hundred and sixty million dollars
it became one of the highest grossing
films in history during the 1977 holiday
season the Star Wars craze caught
everyone by surprise so much the toy
companies had to sell action figure io
use so for about $9 you buy a card
envelope the recipient mailed a
certificate to the manufacturer who will
send the dolls later as production on
the second film progressed through 1978
director George Lucas wanted to keep
Star Wars on everybody's minds through
the next holiday seasons so he approved
CBS to produce the holiday special with
a dream team of variety show creators
and a budget of about a million dollars
but making a song-and-dance version of a
visually stunning space opera was a
tricky combination from the start it's
inexplicable to put those fujian roof
together that's Lenny rips he was
brought in as a co-writer to work on the
wookie scenes I suspected there are two
Star Wars fans who hate me but you see
at the time riding through the pressure
because it was not where it is now and
that led to lines like this
[Music]
my other long hairy face there simply
wasn't a precedent for what the expanded
world of Star Wars should look like I
think it was early on enough that you
could play with it and you can't play
with it now you were still able to have
fun with Star Wars to look at it as
something that's not so culturally
important that not to adhere to every
rule makes you a heretic after the
special aired with Lucas's name nowhere
to be seen in the credits it was never
released again Lucas allegedly said that
he'd smash every copy with a
sledgehammer if he could
he has disavowed and disowned Star Wars
Holiday Special
I mean actively actively it was very
very important to him to have control of
the universe and he lost control of the
universe here this bizarre TV special
was a rocky first foray into what the
world of Star Wars looked like outside
of the movies but it certainly wasn't
the last there have since been hundreds
of Star Wars books video games comic
books and TV episodes some of them were
critical and commercial successes like
Timothy Zahn's Thrawn novels or the
shadows of the Empire multimedia project
and their vision and fell in line with
the universe Lucas had created others
like comics with Jackson a green
anthropomorphised a rabbit or straight
to TV movies featuring sure all a
shape-shifting which didn't exactly feel
like they belong to the Star Wars all of
this material became known as the
expanded universe it contributed to
building out this massive fictional
world in its own way but it was messy
there was a lot of material of varying
quality and contradicting plot points
like clashing back stories about Boba
Fett's real name so in the early 2000s
Lucasfilm developed a continuity
database called the holocron it divided
the Canon into a hierarchy with the
movies at the top and things like the
holiday special on a lower priority
level Disney's four billion dollar
acquisition of Lucasfilm in 2012 changed
all that
the production company put together a
team responsible for giving the
Cinematic Universe a simpler
cohesive continuity only the original
films and prequels plus the Clone Wars
movie and TV show were considered
official storylines everything else in
the expanded universe was branded as
legends and deemed non-canon to the
franchise for many fans that felt like
losing a richly detailed world today the
vast majority of the star wars wiki
articles are about things that aren't
considered part of the official Star
Wars world anymore
but even though these stories aren't
recognized like they used to be the
impact of the ideas behind them can be
seen today the current trilogy is
telling new stories but many themes like
Han and Leia's Sun turning to the dark
side Luke's Jedi Academy and a new
version of the Empire all have their
roots in the expanded universe more than
40 years after the first release Star
Wars hasn't stopped evolving and the
massive messy body of work that lives
outside the movies continues to shape
the way we perceive that world
loyal to George and I owe him so much he
at one time said would you consider
playing an obi-wan type character
handing X caliber down to the next
generation I said women that would that
be and at the time he said around all
around 2011
[Music]